cette courgettes ne passera pas l'hiver
elle était destinée au compost mais
finalement elle sera coupée en rondelles
pour la préparation de plats mitonnés
par ses élèves changent en couper les
courgettes pour le beignets de
courgettes
donc je les coupe doit cm cette équipe
de jeunes collégiens va passer
l'après-midi chez ce traiteur ils vont
préparer différents plats pour
l'entreprise sociale et solidaire qui
l'ont créé food truck et pour donner
naissance à leur projet ils ont mis la
main à la pâte de a à z
on a travaillé tous ensemble et on a
fils elle finalisé avec le graphiste on
a fait toutes les affiches on a trouvé
un traiteur ils ont entre 12 et 16 ans
et ancrer leur mini entreprise dans le
cadre d'un atelier au sein du dispositif
relais du bassin chalon louhans
ce dispositif accueille des jeunes en
risque de décrochage scolaire ou qui ont
décroché
l'objectif de ce type d'action est
d'aider à la re socialisation et à la
rescolarisation on cherche en fait à ce
qu'il reprenne confiance en neuf ans
leur capacité en leurs potentialités qui
remplissent leurs valises de fierté et
pour pouvoir après être plus motivé sur
le scolaire et pouvoir mieux persévérer
et leurs actions à une valeur solidaire
car avant d'être coupés en rondelles la
courgette du début de notre sujet a été
livré le matin par la banque alimentaire
l'association a fourni le surplus de
matière première de ses stocks mais elle
sera également bénéficiaire du troc des
jeunes cuistots
ils vont troquer ses plats cuisinés dans
une grande surface contre des boîtes de
conserve
pourquoi des boîtes de conserves parce
que la banque alimentaire manque
cruellement de produits protéinés
donc pour nous tous qui est conserves de
poissons de thon sardines maquereaux et
cetera
c'est très important vous rappelez
galettes de pommes de terre différents
plats seront proposées lors de
l'opération de troc dans un centre
commercial